>> Greg: VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS IS HELD CLAIMING
VOTER I.D. LAWS WON'T WORK IN
RURAL AMERICA BECAUSE APPARENTLY
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE AREN'T
SMART ENOUGH.
>> I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
UNDERESTIMATE WHAT THAT COULD
MEAN.
IN SOME PEOPLES MINDS, THAT
MEANS, "WELL, YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO XEROX OR PHOTOCOPY
YOUR I.D. TO SEND IT IN TO PROVE
YOU ARE WHO YOU ARE."
WELL, THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
SPECIAL PEOPLE LIVING IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES, THERE'S NO KINKO'S,
THERE'S NO OFFICEMAX NEAR THEM.
>> Greg: JUST TO LET HER KNOW,
THERE'S NO KINKO'S IN RURAL
AREAS BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
KINKO'S AT ALL.
THEY WERE BOUGHT OUT BY FEDERAL
EXPRESS IN 2000, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, AND THEY HAD THEIR SIGNS
TAKEN DOWN IN 2006.
SCORE ONE FOR THE GUTFELD!
[LAUGHTER]
ANYWAY, LAWRENCE, I LOOK AT THIS
AS PROGRESS.
WHEN A MAKING THE VOTER I.D. ARE
GIVEN, THEY USED TO JUST BE
INSULTING BLACK PEOPLE.
NOW IT'S WHITE PEOPLE.
WE ARE ALL STUPID ACCORDING TO
THE DEMOCRATS!
>> Lawrence: BEFORE I ADDRESS
THAT POINT, CAN WE TALK ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS FOR A SECOND?
SHE'S NOT GOOD AT OFF-THE-CUFF!
IT IS -- WHY THEY CONTINUE TO
SEND HER TO DO INTERVIEWS, I
DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A BAD STRATEGY FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SHE'S BECOME A LIABILITY FOR THE
MESSAGE, BECAUSE SHE'S NOT
PREPARED, EVER, EVEN FOR THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE PREPARED.
I'M GLAD YOU POINTED OUT THAT
SHE'S NOW INSULTING ALL PEOPLE.
I THINK THEY REALIZED THEY LOST,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE BLACK
BUSINESS OWNERS.
THEY ARE PISSED OFF ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN ATLANTA.
THE FACT THAT THEY WENT TO
COLORADO, AND THEIR LAWS ARE
WORSE!
I THINK IT WAS A SLAP IN THE
FACE, SO JUST TAKE HER OFF.
JUST TAKE HER OFF THE TRAIL.
NO MORE INTERVIEWS.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S PREPARED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT, I SAID
THIS BEFORE, JESSICA.
IN HER DEFENSE, SHE REMINDS ME
OF ME WHEN I DON'T WANT TO DO
SOMETHING.
I JUST DO THE WORST JOB
POSSIBLE.
OFFICEMAX ON "FOX & FRIENDS"?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I WAS TERRIBLE
HOSTING IT,
THEY NEVER ASKED ME AGAIN ITS
STRATEGY.
I FIND HER ARRESTING,
IRONICALLY.
>> Jessica: THAT IS A TOUGH
BACKHANDED -- I WAS JUST GOING
TO LEAD WITH, I WOULD OBVIOUSLY
NOT HAVE HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT
VOTER I.D. THAT REVOLVED AROUND
XEROX MACHINES AND THE PROXIMITY
TO --
>> Lawrence: SO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT?
>> Jessica: I HAVE NOT
ENCOUNTERED A SINGLE PERSON OF
ANY POLITICAL DENOMINATION WHO
DEFENDED IT.
NOW, THE LARGER DISCUSSION ABOUT
VOTER I.D. THAT I THINK WE ARE
ALL EXCITED TO HAVE AS ADULTS AT
THE TABLE, BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
LOVE IT WHEN I SAY --
>> Jesse: HERE YOU GO COME IN
YOUR IVORY TOWER!
>> Greg: I LIVE IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY.
WHAT IS AN ADULT LIKE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
11% OF AMERICANS DON'T HAVE
VALID GOVERNMENT PHOTO I.D.
JIM CLYBURN IS NOW
SAYING -- WELL, TAKE IT UP WITH
THE BRENDAN CENTER.
>> Jesse: I WILL TAKE IT UP
WITH THE BRENDAN CENTER!
[LAUGHTER]
JIM CLYBURN, WHO I THINK REALLY
HAS HIS FINGER ON THE PULSE OF E
GOING TO WIN ELECTIONS, HE
ORDAINED JOE BIDEN THE NOMINEE
IN SOUTH CAROLINA AND EVERYTHING
WAS GRAVY FROM THERE.
HE IS BACKING THE CLAIM WHICH
REQUIRES PHOTO I.D. BUT IT CAN
BE SOMETHING LIKE UTILITY BILL.
I THINK THAT IF REPUBLICANS ARE
DESPERATE -- OR A PHONE BILL,
ANYTHING YOU GET AT YOUR HOME.
BECAUSE THERE ARE ISSUES WITH
PEOPLE MATCHING BIRTH
CERTIFICATES TO THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY CARDS,
ET CETERA, ESPECIALLY FOR
ELDERLY VOTERS AND BLACK AND
LATINO COMMUNITIES.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT GETTING
SOMEWHERE WITH THAT, JOHN LEWIS
FOR --
>> Lawrence: SO IF IT'S FREE
IDs FOR EVERYONE, DOES THAT
REMOVE THE ISSUE ABOUT VOTER
I.D.?
IF EVERYONE GETS AN I.D.?
>> Jessica: I THINK --
>> Lawrence: LETS DO IT.
>> Jesse: THE THING IS, I
THINK THE CHALLENGE THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE IS THEY CAN NEVER
ACTUALLY FIND SOMEBODY THAT THEY
CAN SHOW AS AN EXAMPLE.
HERE'S TOM STEVENS, HE DOESN'T
HAVE AN I.D.
THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THIS
GROUP, BUT IT'S NOT THERE, AND
IT'S BECAUSE, JESSE, THEY KNOW
THAT IT DOESN'T -- IDs TO MAKE
IT HARD TO VOTE, THEY MAKE IT
HARD TO CHEAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT SOUND
LIKE, "IT'S MAKING IT HARD TO
VOTE."
THEN SHOW ME ONE PERSON!
SHOW ME ONE.
>> Jesse: ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER, THEIR 40 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO CAN'T PROVE THEY
ARE!
THIS 40 MILLION IF YOU GUYS OUT
THERE!
>> Greg: WE WILL HAVE TO
REALLY DIG INTO THAT ONE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT WHEN!
>> Dana: THEY'RE ALL IN THE
NICU.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT WHEN!
I LIVE AT THE TEXAS GOVERNOR
SAYS.
"WE WANT TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
VOTE, HARDER TO CHEAT."
HOW DO YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT?
EASIER TO VOTE, HARDER TO CHEAT.
[LAUGHTER]
DID YOU SAY THAT?
BECAUSE HE SET IT ON THE
WEEKEND.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS WET,
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENTS,
DEADLINES, UNDERSTANDING THE
CHAIN OF CUSTODY, TRANSPARENCY
IN THE COUNT ROOMS.
ALL YOU WANT TO KNOW IS WHAT'S
GOING ON AND WHO YOU ARE IS YOU
SAY YOU ARE.
NONE OF THAT CONFLICTS WITH
MAKING IT HARDER TO VOTE.
NONE OF THAT.
SO WHEN I SEE KAMALA HARRIS, YOU
KNOW SHE GETS THAT SHOULDER
THING GOING?
SHE GOES, "IT'S A DEMOCRACY."
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
WHAT IS THE THING SHE DOES WITH
HER HEAD?
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT A DEEP
POINT.
>> Dana: IT'S KIND OF LIKE
THAT.
>> Jesse: IS THAT HER
SIGNATURE MOVE?
IT'S LIKE, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
LIE TO ME, MAKE IT CONVINCING.
SHE ACTUALLY CARES ABOUT
OBSTACLES OF VOTING IN RURAL
AMERICA?
SHE DOESN'T CARE IF SOMEONE IN
WYOMING HAS TO DRIVE 40 MINUTES
TO A KINKO'S.
SHE CARES IF SOMEBODY IN ATLANTA
OR PHILLY OR DETROIT HAS TO WAIT
FIVE MORE MINUTES.
AND ALMOST APPRECIATED IF SHE
WOULD SAY, "I WANT TO BE EASIER
TO VOTE FOR ANYBODY, I DON'T
CARE IF THERE'S FRAUD."
"THERE'S GOING TO BE FRAUD,
THAT'S FINE, I WANT TO MAKE IT
EASIER."
ALL WE WANT OUR GUARDRAILS.
WHY IS IT SO DIFFICULT?
NO ONE CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION
YET.
>> Greg: DANA, TO JESSE'S
POINT, IT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
PARTY ABOUT BIG GOVERNMENT AND
SOLUTIONS.
WE CAN SOLVE THE PANDEMIC, WE
CAN GO DOOR TO DOOR, WE CAN DEAL
WITH SYSTEMATIC, SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
WE HAVE ALL THESE BIG SOLUTIONS.
BUT VOTER I.D., IT'S LIKE, "OH,
MY GOD, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO!"
WHY CAN'T YOU JUST SEND OUT
IDs?
>> Dana: I FEEL LIKE IT'S A
HUGE HURDLE FOR DEMOCRATS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, BUT THE POLLING
AMONGST BLACK AMERICANS AND
LOW-INCOME COMMUNITIES IS THAT
THEY LIKE VOTER I.D.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
CONGRESSMAN CLYBURN IS LIKE, "I
CAN BE FOR THAT."
KAMALA HARRIS' TEAM HAS BEEN
BACK CHANNELING FOR A WHILE THAT
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
ASSIGNMENTS SHE IS GIVEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE HARD.
BUT SHE ASKED FOR THIS
ASSIGNMENT.
IN GEORGIA, ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY DID, REMEMBER THAT TERRIBLE
LAW?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A COPY OF
YOUR I.D., YOU JUST HAVE TO
WRITE DOWN THE I.D. NUMBER ON
THE THING SO THEY CAN MATCH IT.
THAT'S THE REQUIREMENT.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE TOO HARD
TO DO, PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE CAN
GET A PEN.
>> Greg: NOT IF THERE'S NO
KINKO'S, WHERE DO YOU GET THE
PEN?
>> Dana: THERE WAS A BIG
UPROAR.
SHE SAID, "WE WILL PAY FOR
EVERYBODY, WE WILL PICK YOU UP
AND TAKE IT IN PLACE AND TAKE
YOU HOME."
I THINK SHE HAD SOMETHING LIKE
30 PEOPLE IN THE WHOLE STATE AND
THEN THAT ISSUE WENT AWAY.
SO IT CAN GO AWAY.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY HIS
TEXAS DEMOCRATS TODAY HAVE ALL
LEFT THE STATE IN A HUFF BECAUSE
THEY ARE PROTESTING THIS VOTER
BILL, THAT THE TEXAS LEGISLATOR
IS PUTTING THROUGH.
THEY ARE COMING TO D.C.
WHY?
BECAUSE D.C. HAS THE SOLUTIONS?
RATHER THAN STAYING IN THEIR
STATE AND TRYING TO WORK IT OUT,
COMING TO WASHINGTON --
>> Greg: YOU MEAN YOU CAN
LEAVE WOR